tous les matins en allant au bureau il
passe devant le monument qui fait la
fierté de sa ville le kilomètre zéro
on peut voir sur la droite la banque qui
symbolise le kilomètre zéro la route de
la soie commence ici au niveau du parc
logistique avec les deux gares
[Musique]
sur 40 ans les chinois vont bâtir des
lignes de chemin de fer des lignes
maritimes et des routes tous azimuts
vers l'europe
vers l'asie
et vers l'afrique
partout ils implantent des gares des
ports
des zones industrielles l'ambition c'est
de redessiner les cartes économique et
politique du monde à leur profit c'est
le président chinois xi jinping lui même
qui a concocté ce projet la première
fois qu'il l'a évoqué c'était le 7
septembre 2013
lors d'un discours à l'université
d'astana au kazakhstan en irak
[Applaudissements]
avec 1000 milliards de dollars
d'investissements les nouvelles routes
de la soie c'est le plan de
développement le plus cher de l'histoire
de l'humanité
tout commence à chongqing sur les bords
du lions'club
vous en avez sans doute jamais entendu
parler
c'est pourtant au coeur de la chine
l'une des plus grandes agglomérations du
monde 30 millions d'habitants
c'est plus du double de l'île de france
dans les années 40
la ville comptait un million et demi de
personnes qui vivaient dans de petites
maisons en bois sur pilotis
seul le fleuve les relier au reste du
pays
[Musique]
aujourd'hui zhongxing se targue d'être
le point de départ de ces nouvelles
routes de la soie
[Musique]
joshi fans et membre du bureau du parti
communiste chargé des réseaux ferrés de
chongqing
tous les matins en allant au bureau il
passe devant le monument qui fait la
fierté de sa ville le kilomètre zéro
on peut voir sur la droite la bande qui
symbolise le kilomètre zéro la route de
la soie commence ici au niveau du parc
logistique avec les deux gars c'est
d'ici qu'est parti le tout premier train
chargé de marchandises à destination de
l'europe en mars 2014
à l'origine petites gares de province
chongqing est devenu en cinq ans le plus
grand carrefour ferroviaire du sud ouest
de la chine
joshi fans et fils de cheminot et
cheminots lui-même son travail de
membres du parti
c'est de tout savoir de ce qui se passe
dans la gare vous voyez cette locomotive
c'est le premier modèle de notre gamme
électrique
on le surnomme le grand danger car il
est très long et vraiment très gros ce
sont ceux-là qu'on utilise pour les
trains qui vont vers l'europe
la puissante locomotive ne fera qu'une
petite partie du trajet la ligne n'est
pas encore électrifié jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
chongqing voit partir trois trains par
jour pour l'europe comme celui ci une
quarantaine de wagons chargés de
vêtements de téléphones portables et de
produits chimiques
le trajet dure 15 jours soixante
conducteurs vont se relayer sur les dix
mille kilomètres de la ligne
elle contourne le tibet traverse la
région du czink yang puis parcours cinq
pays le kazakhstan la russie la
biélorussie la pologne jusqu'au terminus
à duisbourg en allemagne
de là les marchandises seront réexpédiés
vers toute l'europe
[Musique]
ans